if you find your training boring
you shouldn't be doing it
full stop and i don't just mean because
it's hard to be consistent with
something that you don't enjoy doing i
don't just mean because it's no fun i
mean that you won't progress as quickly
if you aren't engaged with what you're
doing
unfortunately a lot of people think of
working out as being terribly boring by
definition perhaps you're picturing
standing on the spot curling something
or doing a regular squat for the 1000th
time this year i mean yeah that's pretty
meh but training should not be boring
training is the most action most of us
will get in our day-to-day lives it
should be challenging and adrenaline
pumping moreover if your training is
dull and boring then you aren't going to
get the most from it that's because as
andrew huberman often explains attention
is the key to plasticity our brains are
wired to learn from events that we deem
important without attention none of the
important chemicals that are supposed to
stimulate neuroplasticity will be
produced
so just why is your training boring and
what can you do about it
simple we train like an action hero
[Music]
three sets of 10 is 30 repetitions of
the precise same movement doing anything
30 times is pretty boring when training
for cardio or conditioning we need even
longer sets and that can be even more
mind-numbing but here's the thing you
don't need to be doing three sets of
anything you can easily get by
performing just a single set of an
exercise and still have it be highly
valuable
now i know that some people are already
thinking studies suggest that performing
three sets of an exercise is superior to
performing one or two that way you get
more volume but not enough to cause
excessive fatigue but here's the problem
with studies they tend to look at black
and white scenarios three sets versus
two sets with all else being equal they
don't necessarily look at the way that
we can mitigate against the drawbacks of
one method or another they don't always
consider that there are third options
out there
the reason you don't need three sets is
that you can get the same results by
carefully selecting exercises that offer
similar benefits by choosing exercises
that have overlap say for example rather
than performing three sets of bicep
curls you could instead perform one set
of bicep curls one set of bodyweight
curls and one set of hands only rope
climbs each of these will slightly alter
the angle of resistance and the position
of your hand and grip however they're
similar enough that they will still
offer compounding benefits
this way you're also strengthening a
wider number of movement patterns you'll
be getting additional benefits such as
grip strength and core strength and
you'll be making your workouts far more
interesting
there are still arguments for performing
the precise same movement if your only
interest is in growth and if you want to
truly isolate and fatigue a specific
muscle group likewise if you're trying
to learn a specific technique then
there's not much better than rote
repetition but for most of us looking to
just look and feel a little bit stronger
while also becoming more functional and
more mobile one set of three similar
exercises is perfect it's superior even
or if you want to sit on the fence then
you can perform two sets of exercises
instead and that's pretty much what i do
most of the time
and it's not just the movement itself
that you can vary it's also the
difficulty the tempo and the structure
for example even when i do do multiple
sets of a single exercise i'll often mix
it up with a drop set or i'll include an
isometric hold at the end perhaps one
set is fast and heavy the other is slow
and light there's lots of ways to mix
things up of those three bicep exercise
examples i just gave the rope climb is
probably standing out as potentially the
most exciting for most people but why is
that what makes that more interesting
well firstly the rope climb uses far
more of the body and far more complex
movement patterns so you're going to be
moving hand over hand bracing your core
and engaging your grip then there's the
slight element of risk get this wrong
and you could fall off the rope onto
your ass and because you're swinging
around and you're climbing you'll also
activate the vestibular system all this
signals to the brain that something
interesting is going on and it forces
you to pay attention and because each
movement is slightly different owing to
the way the rope moves and your body
swings you need to pay attention each
time another way to put this is that the
activity is stimulus rich compare this
to simply standing in place curling
dumbbells and the difference is stark
you can literally curl dumbbells with
your eyes closed there's not much to
teach here or to learn so when you're
training try to involve more of your
body more of your senses and ideally
your brain
we are most engaged when we're learning
we tend to think of learning as dull
also but actually learning is the very
definition of fun hear me out here
computer games hold our attention so
well because they're a form of learning
it's through trial and error that you
learn to jump over that piranha plant
and not into it the sound effects and
colorful graphics simply reinforce this
learning process but if the game's too
easy it suddenly becomes no fun
take away the challenge take away the
sensory stimulation you're basically
left with a boring beep test
so now try and apply those same
principles to your training whether that
means giving yourself challenges to
complete playing music combining
exercises into longer flows or hybrid
exercises or just training with more
varied tools and locations this is a
reason that calisthenics can be so
effective the handstand push-up isn't
just a strength move it's also a skill
that needs to be learned so is the squat
of course but the problem comes when all
you do is squat with more and more
weight without introducing any new
variables or wrinkles to increase the
challenge and to get the brain involved
another option is to go somewhere
entirely new whilst you're training and
this adds further stimulation and
interest so i've spoken in a few videos
about the power of training outdoors and
in natural environments simply doing the
same exercises in the woods will
introduce new variables uneven terrain
wind mud and it will flood your senses
with interesting things to look at now
you may find that you need to lighten
the weights you use in this scenario and
you might find that you don't get as
strong as quickly as you otherwise would
the result is that your training is no
longer boring and you'll also be
building a more robust set of movement
patterns and strengthening yourself at
slightly different angles this is more
similar to the kind of farmer strength
the real world strength i do recommend
that you first learn the movement in a
controlled environment but you can then
take it outside to effectively field
test it to see how it works in the real
world you've got your basic movements
down now how does this hold up in a real
chaotic environment
and this way we can also introduce more
context so for example instead of
deadlifting if you move a pile of rocks
from one side to the other not only is
this a more complex and varied movement
we can now also more immediately see the
benefits of what you're doing and how it
might apply to the real world
therefore it becomes more interesting
and finally think about what you're
doing and why you're doing it a lot of
people train just to look good and then
they wonder why their workouts are
boring looking good doesn't require much
movement but if you train to be an
action hero then things get interesting
training to jump higher means your
workouts will naturally need to involve
explosive leaping if you train to be
faster you'll be moving quickly if you
train for complex skills you'll be
balancing and juggling and doing complex
things variety is the spice of life so
by training cross modally you get to
experience all these things at once by
training like an action hero you get to
experience some action
and speaking of which if you're looking
for training that's more about action
and being able to do cool stuff then you
might enjoy my ebook and training
program my new ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
the protein performance system that just
launched there's a launch discount on
right now however not only do you get an
ebook this time a brand new 80 plus page
ebook and a training program as before a
new training program that's more
efficient and streamlined and easier to
apply to literally anyone you also this
time get two hours of video tutorial
which is available through a learning
platform which is now part of the
bioneer website this will show you how
to perform every single movement it'll
tell you what the benefits are so you
can follow along and know exactly what
you need to do
or so that you can apply those
principles to your own training it takes
everything i've learned since the last
book was launched and it just takes an
even deeper dive into human performance
and some of the more interesting and
there's a printable version and you can
print out the programs as well to follow
and the programs are suitable for people
of any level can be performed anywhere
with very minimal equipment all you're
going to actually need are dumbbells and
a pull-up bar
anything else can be swapped out or
skipped over entirely and i give plenty
of variations on alternative exercises
to basically suit every goal in every
situation
it is the closest thing to the way i
train and i can genuinely say that it's
massively improved my performance and
the way i feel on a day-to-day basis
so i really hope you guys benefit from
it and enjoy it too
sorry for the long plug but i'm really
excited about this i've been working on
it for over a year you might have seen
the awesome trailer that grant made for
me so yeah check it out if you're
interested i'll put a link in the
description down below
and thank you so much but either way i
just want to thank you for watching this
video uh if you did enjoy it please
leave a like and share around that helps
me out immensely comment down below and
let me know how you make your training
more interesting exciting and stay tuned
for more like this thank you so much for
watching guys and i'll see you next time
bye for now
you